Speaker 1: Last thing I want to look at on the
Trump riot hearings, day two before we go to a
break. There are often stories that become
stories for good reason, like, for example,
that Rudy Giuliani was appearing regularly
drunk in different places and was giving people
bad advice on the basis of being drunk. And
whenever it would come up and we've talked
about it before, there were people on the
right who would just deny it and there would
be some who would come out and say, you're
making fun of alcoholism. And of course,
we are not making fun of alcoholism. Alcoholism
is a serious disease, very serious, horrible,
horrible disease. The issue was whether there are
people close to Donald Trump giving him advice
who are not in a proper state of mind to be doing
so. And it was widely reported that Rudy Giuliani
was moved from appearing on TV at night to the
morning with the idea that maybe he would not
be drunk in those cases. And it was just a
widely understood and reported thing. Well,
yesterday's hearing started with Liz Cheney. One
of the things that turned out in the investigation
is that Rudy Giuliani was regularly drunk
and giving Donald Trump advice. And,
you know, to be perfectly frank, it sort of makes
everything more logical because the storyline
that Trump ultimately attached to makes a lot more
sense. If you say it, it's an inebriated person's
storyline. It's like, Oh, okay, well, that's so
obvious that it sounds like what a drunk person
would say happened at the election. Take a listen.
Speaker 3: You will hear firsthand testimony
that the president's campaign advisers urged
him to await the counting of votes and not to
declare victory on election night. The president
understood even before the election that many more
Biden voters had voted by mail because President
Trump ignored the advice of his campaign experts
and told his supporters only to vote in person.
Donald Trump knew before the election that the
counting of those mail in ballots in several
states would not begin until late in the day,
would not be complete for multiple days. This was
expected, reported and widely known. You will also
hear testimony that President Trump rejected the
advice of his campaign experts on election night
and instead followed the course recommended by an
apparently inebriated Rudy Giuliani to just claim
he won and insist that the vote counting stopped.
Speaker 1: So one of the big questions and one of
the big things that is fascistic and authoritarian
is just say you won. Just say you won is sort of
the motto of this entire this entire farce,
right, to say you won. And that's what Trump
did. He came out at two something in the morning
on Election Day and said, I won. And we now have
learned it was apparently the drunk idea of Rudy
Giuliani. And, of course, just as a reminder,
many instances of Rudy apparently drunk. Here's
one that we covered. This was a 911 dinner where
Rudy gave a very I'm not with it, Rudy Giuliani.
Speaker 4: Tony Blinken or Miley Hunter.
How's that guy? A general Jesus? The other
day, he said that the Bagram Air Force
Base is not strategically important. I wanted
to grab spot. Five stars. Ten stars. 12 stars.
There are so many stars to come and I'm
sure was years. I wanted to grab his stars,
shove it down his throat and
say it's 400 miles in China. S.
China is going to be our enemy for the next
40 years. You have an airbase 400 miles
from them and you're giving it up. Idiot.
Speaker 1: Yeah. That may be the most drunk
anyone has ever been at any kind of
major speech. So every claim backed up
by the investigation so far. Day
three is today and we will have
more coverage tomorrow. Quick break. Back
after this. Find me on Twitter at D Pacman.